قالت وزرته خارجيه بيلاروسيا ان الرؤوس
النوويه الروسيه التي ساجري نشرها في
البلاد لن تكون تحت امره السلطات
واضافت الخارجيه البيلاروسيه في بيان ان
وجود الرؤوس النوويه في بيلاروسيا لا
يخالف معاهده حظر الانتشار النووي
وتابعت ان بيلاروسيا ارغمت على اتخاذ
خطوات لتحقيق الامن في مواجهه زياده
محتمله لانتشار النيتو بدول الجوار
من جهته قال السفير الروسي لدى واشنطن
ان موقف الولايات المتحده من التعاون
بلادهم مع بيلاروسيا في المجال النووي
مثال واضح على ازدواجيه معايير السياسه
الامريكيه حسب وصفه اضاف انطونوفو ان
واشنطن تلعب منذ 60 عاما دورا مركزيا في
البعثات النوويه المشتركه لحلف الناتو عن
طريق نشر اسلحتها النوويه التكتيكيه في
اراضي خمس دول غير نوويه وهي بلجيكا
والمانيا وايطاليا وهولندا وتركيا
من ناحيتها اعتبرت المتحدثه باسم الخارجيه
الروسيه ماريا خروف ان من السداجه عدم
اعتماد اي اجراءات عسكريه مضاده من قبل
موسكو ردا على ما وصفته بالحرب الهجينه
الشامله التي شنها الغرب ضد روسيا اضافه
ان بلادها تحتفظ بحق اتخاذ خطوات اضافيه
لضمان امنها وامن حلفائها في مواجهه الغرب
الذي اعلن انه يسعى لالحاق هزيمه
استراتيجيه بروسيا على حد قولها